it's hard out there yeah
so actually how are you did you um for
five or six years once I was 18 this is
rated called a 25
until I quit your shopping um when I was
six I'm gonna to foster care unless I
was in in and out of foster care so I
was like 13 and then once I was 13 my
grandma put me into foster care
first permanently you know she ain't
your boy like she gave up cuz like she
she gave up all my mom is a crack addict
my dad died of a heroin overdose when I
was six
so and then I ran away from group homes
and I was on the run from 13 to 18 and I
was yeah I ended up here yep I came down
here looking for heroin I didn't know
where to find it when I came from Mexico
I was in Mexico for a couple of years
and that's where I got strung out and
then I came back to LA cuz me and my
boyfriend broke up there and yeah I
didn't know where to find any heroin so
that's how I ended up on Skid Row
sorry here yeah
here what you started doing it ready 18
kg yeah
so no 18 and 9 I came here when I was 19
so 18 and 19 I was a year I was in
Mexico strung out and then I came
straight from Mexico on the train - it's
a comm unit station yeah right here
dear family by the in Europe yeah I have
them two sisters and two brothers all
younger except my twin brother he's one
minute older
did you talk to
boy yeah I'm with a guy I'm staying with
a guy now I'm in East LA I met him down
here it's not really my boyfriend but I
kind of have to like Virginia's you know
it's it's day there and girls a
Constitution it's like 19 since I came
down here
do you have Christmas stories there
because a lot of girls is like yeah I
got kidnapped for four days and raped
they took me over to Hoover and Imperial
Highway and held me there for like four
days and that's where I learned you know
I learned a lot from that experience not
to go with any black guys and you know
to really trust my intuition with the
guys that I'd go with so now yeah I
don't go with any black guys how do I
get out of that situation well they were
the guy in his girlfriend they were high
on meth and so they fell asleep after
four days and the girl left the keys
because I was locked it was all barred
windows and like Bart you know those
black doors screen doors that are metal
and had a lock from the inside and I
snuck in their room and I saw that the
keys were inside this little plastic
like Rubbermaid drawers I could see him
so I got like a washcloth and I picked
up the keys quietly
there's like a thousand keys and I just
tried them on and I finally got out and
I just ran with no shoes and a half
naked yeah I looked so bad it was really
embarrassing
it was really sick I mean really you had
to get you know something to get well
it's ready to get over yeah I think God
I don't know what they were gonna do
with me
they said they're gonna pimp me out but
I don't think that they would have been
able to trust me maybe they would have
killed me or something you know it's
really scary so now now I always have
like no weapons with me and stuff you
don't want that every day we're going to
see yourself in five years what like to
be doing good kids
no no I want kids but not not like this
hopefully I'll be sober you know have my
own place
have a job probably just getting on my
feet you know but I like to be without a
guy you know yeah my own thing we're
good yeah
a good guy not somebody I have to be
with just like how I miss this guy now
yeah yeah yes actually thank you for
talking to me yeah thank you